[Música]
ou há muito voltar a todos
antes de mais é um prazer estar aqui no
terek para nós é uma estranha e estamos
a gostar muito do ambiente e os sisos e
demos cinco segundos na sua apresentação
por uma salva de palmas da organização
eu sou joana lima guitarra tal tiago
somos os tripulantes deixa o disco
voador e como qualquer tripulante que
surpresa de um disco voador a primeira
coisa que nós queremos dizer é que vimos
em baixo o que trazemos aqui hoje para
partilhar convosco envolve música ao
vivo
histórias quantos de vocês a ouvir uma
música na rádio em casa em qualquer
sítio já se perguntaram o que terá na
origem criar na raiz daquela música
daquela canção dá aquela letra braço no
ar
enquanto vocês é que já foram investigar
isso o brasil era o hal é que
conseguimos descobrir coisas
surpreendentes quando vamos fazer essa
pesquisa eo melhor é que a forma como
possamos aprender o tema musical é
ampliado no disco voador vemos as
músicas como flúxo tem raízes para nós
a flor é a música ea raiz
a história deu origem esta música
se nós pensarmos que a flor é o rosto
visível da raiz
então também podemos pensar que a música
dá visibilidade a história dela rebbeca
história que dá origem a expor além
disso pensarmos que suas produzem um
efeito as flores muda um contexto porque
as ruas oferecem se perfumam chegam aos
olhos narizes as bocas e através dos
sentidos chegam o pensamento individual
e coletivo e chegam a pensamentos que é
transformar as idéias incitam a mudança
de um certo ponto de vista podemos dizer
que flor da raiz um outro alcance eo
mesmo acontece com a música que dá à
história um outro alcance e este é um
moto que faz mudar o nosso nosso disco
voador
nós acreditamos que esse feito efeito
das flores não pode ser não deve ser
subestimado porque muitas vezes a flor
dá fruto das músicas do nosso repertório
são temas que nós escolhemos a dedo pra
dar visibilidade a idéias acontecimentos
revoluções e movimentos que não podem
ser esquecidos porque o banho não é algo
que devemos dar como adquirido
o bairro tem que ser no triunfo com uma
porta para que o óbvio nunca vença o
banho tem
ser nutrido e nós trazemos duas músicas
para oferecer como quem oferece duas
forças pró sexto lugar em nelas gastar
em nelas e oferecerem por aí
não subestimem o poder que cada um de
vocês tem para produzir um efeito nos
outros para galvanizar os outros e mudar
o que está à volta
esteja mais perto ou mais longe porque
muitas vezes o efeito começa perto mas
chega longe
não substimem o vosso poder de fazer do
mundo um mundo melhor
o primeiro tema que nós vamos tocar no
ai jesus nos deixou no brasil
a primeira é de 68 e segundo é 2015
as duas falam de flores e do efeito que
as pessoas prometem as duas falam
liberdade de humanismo e democracia e o
primeiro tema é composto por geraldo
vandré
na altura da ditadura militar no brasil
que durou 21 anos de 64 85 e tornou se
um hino da resistência ao regime
ditatorial o regime censurou música
geraldo vandré foi perseguido pela
polícia militar
exigi los mas a música flor continuou
porém continua a ecoar com a referência
às ruas como um símbolo de paz um
símbolo do amor e com o refrão que é um
apelo à ação e à união das pessoas para
derrubar a ditadura de geraldo vandré o
tema pra não dizer que não falei das
forças
caminhando e cantando e seguindo a
canção
somos todos iguais em braços dados ou
não
nas escolas nas ruas
[Música]
campos construções caminha e cantando e
seguindo a canção pelos campos a fome em
grandes plantas sorrisos pelas ruas
marsan indecisos contam-nos ainda fazem
da flor seu mais forte refrão e
acreditam nas flores sendo canhoto vem
vamos embora que esperar não
é isso aí quem sabe faz a hora não
espera acontecer
o vem vamos embora que esperar não é
saber
quem sabe faz a hora não espera
acontecer
há soldados armados amados ou não
quase todos perdidos dia mais na mãe nos
quartéis de 5 uma antiga missão ultimou
rei pela pátria e viver sem razão
sinto sobre o assunto
portanto os azuis quando interpelado
anos completos no mundo
chupar o sangue fresco dava na jovem
cigana com seu ar sisudo e os franca e
as cordas a chegada de um documento
neste momento está em tudo e não deixam
nada
ele comentou que os comem tudo eles
comem tudo e não
[Música]
vem vamos embora
é saber quem sabe faz a hora não espera
acontecer
[Música]
vamos embora que esperar não é saber
quem sabe
mas a hora não espera acontecer nas
escolas nas ruas campos com funções nos
todos soldados armados hunan caminhando
e cantando é e seguindo a doença
somos todos iguais braços da doença
os amorim di na man
as flores no chão
a certeza na frente ea história na mão
[Música]
é a minha e cantando e seguindo é nossa
aprendendo e ensinando uma nova lição
vem vamos embora que esperar não é saber
quem sabe faz a hora não espera
acontecer
o vem vamos embora que esperar não é
saber quem sabe faz a hora não espera
acontecer
hum
muito obrigado então a gente já em
outubro
o segundo tema é por caetano veloso e
gilberto gil
tendo vivido esse mesmo regime opressor
que viveu geraldo vandré em 2015 compõem
uma canção chamada as camélias do
quilombo do leblon em 2015 é muito
recente
os quilombos eram locais de refúgio dos
escravos eram construídos constituinte
por grupamentos de negros que
conseguiram escapar dos engenhos de
escravos no brasil entre os séculos 16 e
19 no bairro do leblon no rio de janeiro
nessa altura século 19 havia uma moto
que era propriedade de um floricultor
por cada português josé fez uma
excelente e 60 contra a escravatura e
ajudou a fundação do primeiro quilombo
abolicionista do país
dentre a sua floricultura as flores que
tenham destaque eram as câmeras eram
cultivadas com o auxílio de escravos que
fugiram e que seixas recolheu elas
passaram a ser usadas nas lapelas como
código identificação entre abolicionista
que inclusivamente auxiliavam nas fugas
ilegais dos cravos
é uma forma dos objetivos identificarem
também quem podiam confiar se usassem
uma telenovela também a princesa isabel
era abolicionista e nas aparições que
fazia em público muitas vezes tornava os
seus vestidos com câmeras e isto era
falado nos mais nuno dias quinto e dela
era procurar mobilizar alta sociedade
pré para a viragem antes que o lojista
tanto que mexam um símbolo do movimento
abolicionista no brasil
esta é uma é
a da história que está por trás do tema
que vamos tocar a seguir neste tema do
caetano e gil é explícito como vocês vão
perceber o apelo a uma segunda abolição
e tendo em conta o contexto social e
político que o brasil eo mundo
atravessam não é difícil sentir que este
chamamento pev
na verdade a abolição da nova
escravatura
a lição do racismo da homofobia da
xenofobia da exploração da violência do
óbvio a abolição dos neofascistas que é
uma erva daninha que ganha força quando
nós por algum motivo
baixamos os braços não esqueçam que vem
tem que ser nutrido pelo amor pela
justiça pela diversidade e pela
democracia pela liberdade e pela
dignidade pelos direitos humanos
cantamos agora convosco as camélias do
quilombo do leblon que este nosso
espírito de comunhão vá nesta sala pra
todo lado para todo mundo porque não
esqueçam do que falamos nem se cada um
de nós tem aqui é o extraordinariamente
o manu uber de orientar o mundo provém
[Música]
tudo o resto que mandou as canelas as
camélias do quilombo de lebron é menos
do que no mundo levando as camélias do
quilombo do leblon nas lapelas fim mais
tristes colinas avançou de bruno
nos faz dó seis meninas se sai do tom
que fazer
chegando aqui as câmeras do que no mundo
do livro
[Música]
somos o mar negro
nem toró
somos a guarda negra nada e nem dourar
vamos aguardar a negrada melhorar
as câmeras assim o abolição das camélias
da sertã proença das camélias da segunda
abolição das camélias das camélias a
segunda abolição
a média é segunda dores as camélias da
segunda abolição okada ela e sabe até de
som assim capoeira as ruas o serasa
enfim o sofrido povo do brasil nele e em
mim vi o refrão as camélias a segunda
abolição
o irão tem galinha quem tem câmera litém
gamela em tudo é que tem câmera aqui tem
canalha litém camélia pra toda a g
ei ei shot reputa olhar que ainda dá
para ir a avó ainda ainda dá ainda dá
ainda dói
ai ai ai ir a voto com a gamela ouvir a
voto a voto com câmeras do bar e tudo
vira voto acaba de abrir a volta a
ganhar ea vida volta aqui vira voto com
a mão na virilha volta limpa e virar
volta pra cá minha vida botacin ir a
voto pagar melhor os cafés do quilombo
do leblon das camélias do quilombo
toulon
as câmeras do quilombo lebron as
camélias
[Música]
vim
ais triste
colinas um avanço de hebron e rimos com
as doses meninas
e do tom que fazer
chegando aqui em as câmeras do quilombo
do leblon grande só nos aguarda me
agrada à venda em todo o pará
somos aguarda mercado da menina
somos vanguarda negra da revendedora
as câmeras da segunda polícia as
camélias da segunda bolsa das camélias
da segunda abolição das camélias
as camélias assim fica melhor é a
segunda doença mais velha das camélias a
segunda abolição cada é assim
mas enfim o sofrendo o povo do brasil
[Música]
ele tem em mim
viva o verão as câmeras da central de
polícia
viram as câmeras na segunda abolição das
camélias da segunda abolição das
camélias a segunda abolição
as câmeras
[Aplausos]